[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل اشعلت وفاه الفتاه
مساء اميني نار الغضب لدى الشارع الايراني
حول عده قضايا من بينها القيود المفروضه
على الحريات الشخصيه والقواعد الصارمه
المتعلقه بهذه المراه منذ عام
1979 يفرض النظام الايراني على المراه
الايرانيه شكلا بعينه للازياء في العديد
من النساء الايرانيات حرمنا من حقهن في
متابعه التحصيلهن العلمي او العمل بتهمه
اعتماد قواعد لباس غير ملائمه كما يدعي
النظام في عام
1983 صدر قانون يطالب النساء
بتخطيط رؤوسهن وارتداء ملابس طويله فضفضه
في الاماكن العامه مع فرض غرامه وحتى
السجن على ايدي شرطه الاخلاق في حاله عدم
الامتال لذلك القانون واليوم مع الانباء
حول تعليق دوري شرطه الاخلاق اعلن النائب
في البرلمان الايراني حسين ده ليه اعلن ان
النظام يبحث عن تجميد الحساب المصرفي لغير
المحجبات بدلا من تسيير دوريات الشرطه
الاخلاق واضاف جلال لانه معا انتهاء
الاحتجاجات سيتم تنفيذ خطه الحجاب ما يعني
ان الحجاب سيعود الى رؤوس النساء مهددا
بان السلطات الايرانيه سترفع تكلفه عدم
ارتداء الحجاب
تدخلوا هذه التصريحات او تدخل النظام
الايراني فيما ترتديه المراه الايرانيه
بات سؤالا ملحا لم تعرف دواءه هل هو من
باب اخلاقيه كما يقول ام هو ذاعه لسيطره
على الشعب وقمعه عند الحاجه كما يقول
معارض
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اصله عضو
منظمه حقوق الانسان عماره اهلا بك من
بروكسيل البحث عن الايراني
ان ابدا من بروكسل معك يا سيد منى سيد منى
خلينا نتفق من البدايه باننا لا نناقش هذا
الاجراء فكل دوله لها الحقيقه
مناسبه لنظامها ولكننا نناقش انتقادات
داخل الايراني
يقولون بان فرض هكذا اجراءات هو للحفاظ
على النظام وليس لدوافع اخلاقيه او محافظه
على صوره المراه الى اين مدى هذه
الانتقادات لديها شيء من الصحه
تحياتي لك يا مشاهدين واضيفك من اصله
انا من حقها تفرضها لانه القانون في
النهايه احيانا تكون ظالمه ولازم تغيرها
يعني اذا نفترض في لدينا كان قانون عبوديه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان لدينا
فصل العنصري في افريقيا الجنوبيه هل نقول
انه الافريقيه الجنوبيه كانت قانون
المفروض تفرض حتى ولو كان الظالمه فهذا
المبدا للجمهوريه الاسلامي كثيرا تحاول ان
تبينها في في الاعلام الغربي انه لدينا
قانون ولا لازم تفرق طيب في النهايه انها
جمهوريه وانها ديمقراطيه لان يتم
الانتخابات في حال الشعب في العاده في
الديمقراطيه مبدا الديمقراطيه يقول حكم
الشعب عن الشعب والمفروض الذين هم موضوعين
للقانون يعني هم يصيرون تحت هذا القانون
لكل لديهم حق في تغيير القناه لذلك نحن
اذا لم نطبق هذا المبدا انا فقدنا مفهوم
الديمقراطيه صرنا في دوله استرداد
تحت هذا البنت ممكن نقبل نقول ان هذا
قانونهم يعملوا لها ولكن هذا المنطق لانه
كل دوله لها قانونها اا خلي الناس يحترمون
هذا خارج يعني الحدود الانسانيه في
التعامل بالاخص لقضايا النساء اما بالنسبه
للقانون الحجاب ايرافي لديها كثير من
القوانين غير اسلاميه غير اخلاقيه ولكن من
اجل لحفاظ النظام مستمرين فيها مثلا
القوانين المصرف الايراني على رقم سما
الاسلاميه عليها النظام النظام الربوي
فيها اكثر من 20% حتى في اماكن يصل
المواطن ياخذ حرود من بارك لازم يدفع 40%
يعني هذا يفوق كل حتى المعايير يعني
النظام يتعامل همم بطريقه مختلفه او يكيل
بمكيالين همم في تعامله مع بعض طيب سيد
عمار في الاساس ما قصه هذا القانون الذي
يفرز حجابا على المراه او زي همم همم
فرضه النظام الايراني وما صحه كذلك بعض
التصريحات التي اتت بعد هذا الاجراء بانه
يمكن ان يتم تعديل او على الاقل البحث في
محاوله تعديل هذا القانون والقول بانه بعد
الاحتجاجات سيعود ولكن بشكل مختلف
طبعا
هناك قالوا من الحجاب ولكن لم يحدد الحجاب
ما هو الحجاب فقط بشكل عام متحدث عن هذا
الامر واا منذ قيام الثوره اخذت الحكومه
تطبق هذا النص الموجود في بعض القوانين
لجمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
وتطبقه وفقه ما تريد وفقا ما يتماشى مع
ايدولوجيهتها وفكرتها وفي الحقيقه في
النصوص الفقهيه الشيعيه لا توجد مثل هذا
الشيء انه الحجاب يفرض فرضا من قبل
الحكومه كما ان
الحكومه جمهوريه اسلامي او نظام الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران هو
جاءك يعني في الحقيقه همم بدعه في ال ال
الفقه الشيعي ولم يكن شيئا يوجد هكذا همم
لماذا يفرضه النظام ويشدد على فرضه عبر
السنوات
النظام واحتقد
هو من ناحيه اللون ناقشنا الامر من ناحيه
الاجتماعيه هذا
الموضوع رضا بهلوي اي والد محمد رضا بهلوي
قام بفرض
ه واراد يلبس همم حله الحداثه بالقوه على
المجتمع الايراني
وصارت رده فعل خاصه من قبل رجال الدين في
ذلك الوقت
واعتقد ان في 79 همم جاء الرد من قبل رجال
الدين بالطريقه الاخرى وكما يقال اخذوا من
اخر طبقه ايضا ففرضوا الحجاب بالقوه
وجعل النظام الايراني مثلا لم يجعل متنفس
او لم يجعل بل كان ظالما وشديدا حتى
الاطفال الذين يذهبون المدارس في عمر مثلا
البنات الفتيات الذين ذهبوا المدارس في
عمر ست سنوات يفرض عليهم الحجاب بينما
القصه يعني من ناحيه دينيه ولا يفرق عليها
الحجاب الكتب الدراسيه التي كنا نقراها
ونحن اطفال ايضا كانت بعضها من زمن الشاف
فيها مثلا صغار غير محجبات فكانوا يعملون
عليها رسوم
ويحجبونها وينشرونها في كتب جديده احتقد
منذ البدايه هو اخطا كبير وانه جعل من
الحجاب كرمز له بما انه كان اقبال شديد
على هذا الامر من قبل الجماهير في ذلك
الوقت ولو اخذنا ايضا من هذه الاجتماع في
ذلك الوقت معظم
النيه كانت تفكر بطريقه تقليديه والمجتمع
الايراني كان يعيش في الكره ربما نسبه
كبيره ربما
صحيح وضحت هذه الفكره ولكن خلينا معك يا
استاذ منى نفهم هذه المقاربه ضيف يقول
بانه هناك خطا ارتكبه النظام بفرض مثل
هكذا زي او لباس بعد اثار الايرانيه في
تسع سنوات لبعض الاخر يقول او يضع معادله
فرض لباس مع بقاء النظام يقول بان هذا
يتخطى رمزيه وهو اساس من اسس بقاء النظام
ما رايك في هذا هذه المعادله
اوافق الراي لانه حسب متابعه بعض المحللين
على قنوات الرسميه الايرانيه يقولون في
حال تراجعنا في قضيه الحجاب غدا يقولون
نريد حكم علماني بعد غدا يطالبون بامور
اخرى لا ننسى يعني ممكن لا يوجد اي دوله
في العالم ما عدا ممكن افغانستان وحكم
طالبان انه يمنع دخول النساء الى الملاعب
يعني ايران بهالدرجه تحاول النظام
الايراني التحكم في حياه النساء لان هذه
بالفعل يساعد على سيطره على المجتمع لا
نتخيل مجتمع لا يستطيع ان يقرر كيف يلبس
اكيد لا يستطيع ان يقرر كيف يفكر يعيش
فهذا التدخل المباشر في حياه خاصه الناس
حتى يمنع من الناس يفكرون في قضايا اخرى
مثل الحريات السياسيه وقضايا اقتصاديه لان
كل يوم همم هون اللي تعيشها المراه في
حياتها العامه على فكره هذه القوانين اللي
مثلا ممكن يسكرون الحساب يعني انا كفتاه
عشت في بالفعل حياه اليوميه كل يوم في
المدرسه كنا نتعرف للاهانات في طريقه
لبسنا يعني كان تحكم بكل شيء لون طلاء
الاظافر ممنوع
حتى زين الحواجب ممنوع كان جواريب تخيلي
الجراب لونها ابيض كان ممنوع فكل هذه
الممنوعات في النهايه كلها هذه الضغط اللي
شخص ممكن يعيشه يخلق منه شخص خنوع شخص لا
يستطيع التمرد فكل هذه بالفعل محاور لسيطر
على المجتمع ولكن حتى الان يعني الان وصل
المجتمع يعني الى مرحله لان وصل لحاله
انفجار هذا الحاله اليوميه ممكن حتى تجارب
اللي انا مرت فيها او كانت بالنسبه لي
صدمه كنت في احد المطارات في في في طهران
في في المطار في حال لم تلتزم المراه زي
اللي هم يريدونها ممكن يمنعونها حتى من
الخروج فكانت احد الفتيات وضع مكياج فكانت
خارج من حدود الايرانيه كان عندها جواز
السفر تذهب الى دور اجنبيه وانما تمرده
هناك لما اهنوها قالوا لها لازم تمسح
المكياج وتضايق المزيد من الحجاب همم قالت
انا ذاهبه من البنات سحبوا منها جواز سفر
قررت اذا فيك تضحكي خارج البلاد يعني حتى
الاقامه جبريه في ايران تعتبر همم تعتبر
عقوبه للنساء ليعيشوا في ايران لاني
بهدرجه في تحكم في حياه الناس طب بالفعل
اللي ضغط وما الاسف بسبب جمله اخيره بسبب
انه المجتمع الايراني كان مش مجتمع محافظ
وتقليدي رجال ايضا لم يساعد النساء يعني
من المفروض الرجال يقول للحكومه الايرانيه
انه لماذا ممنوع دخول النساء
بالعدل
بان هناك نسبه كذلك في داخل الايراني
تساند مثل هكذا اجراءات يعني حتى هناك لو
مرق على مجموعات لا نعلم اي نسبه يمكن ان
تمثلها في داخل الايراني ربما يكون هذا
موضوع اخر ولكن ساكمل مع ال- ال-
لا لانه في النهايه هناك حقوق للرجال على
حساب النساء في النهايه قوانين الايرانيه
هي اللي صالح الرجال في قوانين الحضانه في
قوانين الطلاق زواج سفر كل هذه هي عمل
المراه كانها جزء من يعني كم ملكيه خاصه
للرجل فبنوع ما الحكومه بهذه الطريقه قدمت
بعض الامتيازات ايضا الرجال لذلك صار
التحكم في المشروع
الايرانيه على الاقل سيد عمار هي تفكر في
تعديل بعض الاجراءات مثلا عوض كنا تحدثنا
العدد من المرات على دوريات الارشاد والتي
تم تعطيل العمل بها هناك حديث عن انه هذا
الشكل سيحافظ عليها بعد نهايه الاحتجاجات
ولكن بطريقه
ستبدا بالتفكير بارسال نص همم
فيما بعد بالتحذير وفيما بعد بتصليه
عقوبات قد تصل الى اغلاق الحسابات البنكيه
هل تعتقد مع هكذا اجراءات يمكن ان تحتد
الاحتجاجات كيف سيكون تاثيرها على الشارع
عندما يسمعها وعندما يتلقى انباء كهذه
طبعا انا قلت يعني ارجع على السؤال الاول
قلت انه خطا ارتكبه النظام بالحقيقه هو
النظام هو
خطا
فيه نظام لا اعتقد انهما انها سوف تقوم
بمعالجه الموقف وذلك بسبب ان النظام طوال
العقود الماضيه هو اثار واثر بشكل همم
يعني يقوي على فرض الحجاب في المجتمع كما
تفضلت ضايقتك الكريمه ولم يجعل متنفس لهذا
الامر واليوم كما يقال خلقه هو النظام في
سنه 79 خلقه مشكله من لا مشكله وهذه
المشكله منذ ذلك الحين ده الكره التي
تدحرج من فوق جبل كالكره الثلجيه تكبر
وتكبر واليوم اصبحت كبيره بحيث تهدد
النظام بنفسه ولا يستطيع بمعالجه لان الان
اجتماعيا اصبح الامر غير قابل للاحتواء
وحتى انهم قيل قيل من قبل بعض المسؤولين
انه مثلا يقومون بجعل الحجاب قانون ولكن
لا يطبق كما مثلا قوانين امتلاك همم اجهزه
ولكن هذا ليس ممكن لانه يشمل المدارس
دوائر الدوله جميع القطاعات
الحجاب له فقط فقط رمزيه وانما هناك
القوانين التي تطهد المراه التي تحد من
حريه المراه التي تصادم حقوق المراه كما
تفضلت السيده من بروكسل هو ليس فقط الحجاب
هو نفسه وايضا يعني ليس فقط قضيه الحجاب
لكي هل هي قضيه مصادرات الحريه الشخصيه
باكملها الحريات فضلا عن الحريات السياسيه
الحريات الاجتماعيه
هذه كلها همم كلها يعني موجوده والناس
تحتاج على هذا وايضا بعد الذي بعد الذي
حصل اليوم الجماهير تهدف لا تريد اسقاط
النظام كفى كفى يعني النظام كانت لديه
الفرصه ان يعالج اخطاء يعالج ايدولوجته
ولكنه لم يقوم بذلك السياده
للمتابعه اكيد من اسلوبه منظمه حقوق
الانسان عماره نسائي ومن بروكسل الباحثه
الايرانيه منى اسئله و شكرا جزيلا لكم
نتوقف مع فاصل المشاهدين نعود من بعضه
لنتابع
لماذا تدعو المجر الى اعاده النظر في
العقوبات على روسيا وماذا يعني تصريح
مكروه بان الثمن الذي تدفعه اوروبا نتيجه
العقوبات اكبر بكثير مما تدفعه امريكا